vi è mai capitato di trovarvi nella
situazione in cui la vita di un'altra
persona dipende direttamente da quello
che voi rispondete al telefono
beh a me è capitato è capitato alcuni
anni fa mentre stava andando
all'università la stazione di saronno e
a un certo punto mi sono al cellulare da
un numero sconosciuto e dall'altro lato
c'è una signorina molto gentile che mi
dice che contrariamente a tutte le
statistiche ea tutte le probabilità ho
passato anche il secondo test e quindi
sono compatibili e per donare il midollo
osseo e mi chiede che cosa voglio fare
se me la sento davvero di andare avanti
e diventare un donatore o se invece
voglio tirarmi indietro senza alcuna
conseguenza
e senza che nessuno possa mai saperlo
beh voi capite che in quel momento io
sono passato nell'arco di un minuto
dalla vera in testa la lezione che stavo
per fare all'università ad avere in mano
la vita di quest altra persona beh io
quel giorno poi ho deciso di andare
avanti e quindi quattro settimane dopo
più o meno mi sono sottoposto alla
procedura della donazione
quindi mi sono trovato con una pallina
di gomma in mano da stringere e per
cinque ore e mezzo circa attaccato a
questa macchina che ha filtrato tre
volte tutto il mio sangue alla ricerca
delle cellule staminali emopoietiche che
poi sono state trapiantate nel corpo
dell'altra persona e di quel giorno mi
ricordo il calore degli infermieri
mi ricordo il rumore delle macchine e la
sensazione di dover sempre fare pipì
perché il sangue reintrodotte
leggermente più freddo di quello che
viene prelevato beh quando io racconto
questa storia invariabilmente poi
osservo due cose la prima è che mi
chiedono com'è andata a finire
e cioè se l'altra persona poi ce l'ha
fatta si è salvata per davvero anche io
rispondo sempre la stessa cosa e cioè
che io non lo so non lo so non lo posso
sapere perché la donazione del midollo è
sempre in forma anonima e questo per
prevenire che ci siano dei ricatti o
delle transazioni economiche tra le due
parti e quindi io non lo so donatore e
chi riceve la donazione
non si conoscono e non si conosceranno
mai non sapranno mai il destino
dell'altro
beh se volete questo rende l'atto di
decidere di donare il midollo come tante
altre cose un atto quasi puramente
altruistico lo si fa per aiutare qualcun
altro ma senza aspettarsi veramente
qualche cosa in cambio e senza nemmeno
essere sicuri alla fine di essere stati
utili e questo porta la seconda cosa e
cioè che spesso quando sentiamo storie
di questo tipo
beh in tutti noi si genera un
comprensibile sentimento di ammirazione
per queste scelte altruistiche delle
scelte che sembrano in qualche senso
forse un po straordinario un po eroi che
fatte per gli altri beh io vi posso però
assicurare che dal punto di vista di chi
quella scelta si è trovato a farla ma è
la prospettiva è in realtà molto diversa
perché se voi pensate di ricevere quella
chiamata di riceverla voi nella quale vi
si dice che voi ha solo voi potete
decidere di fare la differenza per la
vita di un'altra persona e che l'unica
cosa che dovrete sopportare per provare
a riuscirci è quella di sopportare
alcuni esami di routine del sangue
qualche settimana di spossatezza per via
dei farmaci che dovete prendere e poi un
giorno di sottoporvi a una procedura che
grosso modo simile alla dialisi che la
fanno ogni giorno decine di migliaia di
persone senza troppi problemi
beh se questo è lo scenario allora
quando vi trovate a ricevere quella
chiamata dalla domanda che vi ponete non
è se siete pronti a diventare un eroe
per qualcun altro ma è come faccio a
dire di no ma come si fa a dire di no
quando il bene che tu puoi fare per
un'altra persona è così grande è il
prezzo che ti viene chiesto di pagare è
così piccolo come si fa a dire di no la
mia esperienza di donatore poi alla fine
forse la lezione più importante che io
ho tratto è che l'altruismo è in larga
parte una questione di prospettiva beh
perché un conto è giudicare questa
scelta altruistica quando come voi
sentite la storia è un conto invece
trovarsi
i protagonisti di questa storia qui di
essere voi a ricevere la chiamata di
dover decidere voi come vi volete
comportare nei confronti della vita di
quest altra persona beh anni dopo questa
esperienza
io nella mia vita ho trovato un simile
rivolgimento radicale di nuovo della mia
prospettiva nei confronti dell'altruismo
e questo è accaduto quando mi sono
imbattuto per la prima volta nell idea
di cui vi voglio parlare oggi cioè
l'idea dell'altruismo efficace o
dall'inglese effective altri mesi
beh oggi l'altruismo efficace si conosce
ancora poco nel nostro paese ma in
realtà è un movimento che si sta
espandendo a livello globale è un
movimento il cui primo obiettivo è
quello di portare tutti noi a ripensare
a quello che credevamo di sapere
riguardo all'altruismo e cioè a quello
che noi possiamo fare per gli altri e
per migliorare il mondo ora questo
movimento nasce circa dieci anni fa in
ambito prevalentemente accademico e
infatti non c'è da stupirsi se oggi
ancora oggi due degli esponenti
principali derivano dall accademia qui
ne vedete 21 è peter singer che è il più
famoso e bioeticista oggi vivente un
famoso filosofo morale
accanto al suo libro sul tema che si
chiama the most viewed il weekend e
l'altro più giovane è un giovane
professore associato di oxford che si
chiama william e caschi che ha aiutato
diverse associazioni legate alla turismo
efficace a prendere piede di fianco al
suo ultimo libro che si chiama 2 indrit
deda ecco nei minuti che mi rimangono io
cercherò di prendere alcun idea alcuni
esempi da questi autori e questi testi
per cercare di spiegarmi perché
l'altruismo efficace è veramente una
delle idee più rivoluzionario del xxi
secolo
e perché l'idea dell'altruismo efficace
può contribuire a cambiare anche la
vostra prospettiva rispetto
all'altruismo cioè quello che voi potete
fare per gli altri mettendovi
letteralmente nella condizione di
salvare decine di vite umane
ognuno di voi per farlo userò tra idee
la prima è questa
fare del bene non è abbastanza
fare del bene non è abbastanza perché le
nostre risorse sono sempre limitate e
quindi dobbiamo pretendere di spenderle
bene nelle cose che sono davvero
efficaci e per farvi vedere che cosa
significa guardate questo grafico e
questo esempio immaginiamo di prendere
un problema che è quello per esempio
degli anni di scuola che perdono le
bambine nelle zone povere del mondo per
esempio in uganda e in kenya questo è un
problema legato a doppio filo con il
tema dell'inclusione perché le bambine
che perdono tanti giorni di scuola poi
saranno quelle che faranno più fatica ad
affrancarsi dalla condizione di povertà
nella quale stanno vivendo
e così faranno le comunità in cui queste
bambine vivono
immaginiamo di avere mille dollari a
nostra disposizione e di voler provare
diverse strategie per contribuire a
risolvere questo problema
beh una cosa che possiamo fare è quella
di dare dei soldi direttamente alle
bambine che vanno a scuola e questo
funziona si fa un po di bene aggiunge
0,2 anni di scolarizzazione ogni 1.000
dollari che investiamo un'altra
strategia è quella di dare delle borse
di merito e funzionano un po meglio
in effetti perché per mille dollari
aggiungiamo tre anni di scolarizzazione
oppure possiamo provare a cercare di
capire perché a volte queste bambini non
vanno a scuola è un'ipotesi è che
essendo così povere che hanno una sola
uniforme
quindi quando l'uniforme si sporca o si
rompe
poi si vergognano e non vanno più a
scuola e quindi la soluzione può essere
dare delle uniforme gratuite a queste
bambine e questo funziona molto meglio
in effetti perché aggiunge per mille
dollari investiti in programmi di questo
tipo circa sette anni però c'è una cosa
che funziona molto meglio di tutte
queste è che a nessuno di noi che
viviamo qui in questo paese verrebbe mai
in mente questo qualcosa e dare delle
pillole che costano 20 centesimi per
prevenire quelli che sono i parassiti
gastrointestinali che è un problema
endemico delle zone più povere del mondo
e pensate che per ogni 1.000 dollari che
investiamo gli interventi di questo tipo
non aggiungiamo 7
ho dieci anni aggiungiamo 139 questa è
la differenza che dobbiamo fare e questo
è il perché fare del bene
non basta tutte queste cose fanno del
bene male fanno in maniera tremendamente
differente non possiamo accontentarci di
fare una differenza ma noi dobbiamo
pretendere di fare nella vita degli
altri
la differenza più grande che possiamo
fare la seconda idea è che stessi stessi
soldi diverso valore perché ovviamente
il valore dei soldi dipende da quanti
giorni abbiamo e dove ci troviamo
guardate questo grafico forse alcuni di
voi già lo conosco è il grafico che
mostra la distribuzione della ricchezza
globale
oggi nel mondo siamo più o meno 7
miliardi e 500 milioni e questo grafico
ci dice che grosso modo un quarto di
queste persone un miliardo 700 milioni
più o meno vive
niente un altro 25 per cento vive con
poco o niente il grosso della ricchezza
si concentra dall'altra parte della
curva nell'altra 50 per cento
una precisazione il grafico non è a
completo
il grafico non è completo perché oggi
l'uno per cento è così ricco rispetto a
tutti gli altri che per includerlo in un
grafico grande così avremmo bisogno di
uno schermo alto come un palazzo più di
300 piani però la cosa interessante
capire dove siete voi dove siamo noi in
questo grafico ed è difficile da dire
perché non ci sono gli indici di reddito
e quando lo si chiede alle persone molti
tendono a collocarsi più o meno tra il
iii e il iv quarto
e quindi tra quelli che non sono né
troppo poveri e né troppo ricchi ma se
aggiungiamo gli indici le cose cambiano
drammaticamente perché chiunque
qui in questa sala o tra di noi guadagna
più di 46.000 euro è di fatto nel l'uno
per cento più ricco della popolazione
globale l'uno per cento siamo noi e
chiunque guadagna più di 26mila euro e
di fatto nel 5 per cento più ricco della
popolazione a livello globale
questo che cosa ci dice ci dice che è
ovvio che gli stessi soldi fanno una
differenza diversa a seconda di dove
vengono spesi perché per noi che viviamo
in un posto relativamente molto ricco 5
euro fanno la differenza tra fare
l'aperitivo e non fare
creativo ma 5 euro per chi vive
dall'altra parte del grafico fanno la
differenza letteralmente tra la vita e
la morte
combinando queste due idee arriviamo
alla terza idea che è quella veramente
importante
tutti possiamo fare la differenza perché
perché noi abbiamo così tanto rispetto
agli altri che sia anche sacrifichiamo
pochissimo di quello che abbiamo
possiamo fare moltissimo per tantissime
altre persone soprattutto se le
investiamo in cause che sono
massimamente efficaci e non c'è maniera
migliore di dimostrarvelo che farvi
vedere questo test che lo trovate a
questo sito di un'organizzazione di al
turismo efficace che si chiama giving
what we can
il test si chiama quanto siamo ricchi e
io mi sono permesso di farlo per voi
consideriamo una persona che vive in
italia da sola
dodici mensilità e guadagna 1.300 euro
al mese
l'opera un operaio specializzato più o
meno sappiate che lo stipendio medio
italiano è più o meno 1.500 euro ogni
mese questa persona decide di donare il
10 per cento in case veramente efficaci
se lo fa sarebbe comunque dell 8,6 per
cento più ricco a livello globale e
comunque dopo la donazione avrebbe una
paga che è 13 volte la media a livello
globale
cosa più importante però con quei soldi
ogni anno potrebbe pagare 1384 a
trattamenti contro i parassiti
gastrointestinali di cui vi ho parlato
prima
oppure l'equivalente di 270 reti per
prevenire le infezioni di malaria che
ancora la prima causa di morte nei
contesti dove la povertà è endemica in
entrambi i casi questo equivale a una
cosa cruciale e cioè ogni anno a salvare
una vita
c'è una persona che ha anche uno
stipendio sotto la media ma che decide
di donare in maniera sistematica a cause
veramente efficaci
ogni anno può salvare un'altra vita
umana e questo vuol dire che nel corso
della nostra vita lavorativa
ognuno di noi più o meno 40 anni può
arrivare a salvare donando così 40 al 3d
to male
il che vuol dire che se io continuassi a
fare quello che già sto facendo le prime
tre o quattro file di questa sala sono
il corrispettivo di persone che potrai
contribuire a salvare se altre 27
persone tra di voi decidessero di fare
la stessa scelta
insieme noi potremo salvare alla fine
molte più vite umane di quante ne ha
salvate oskar schindler durante la
seconda guerra mondiale e pensate se
moltiplichiamo questo per tutti quelli
che sono qua in questa sala o per tutti
quelli che sono in questa città o
semplicemente per tutti quelli che
vivono e hanno la fortuna di vivere nel
10 per cento più ricco del mondo
cosa ci dice l'altro efficace beh ci
dice questo ci dice che se noi siamo
così fortunati da avere uno stipendio
mensile e siamo così fortunati da vivere
nel 10 per cento più ricco del pianeta
oggi
beh come se tutti noi adesso stessimo
ricevendo una chiamata una chiamata
analoga è forse ancora più potente di
quella che ho ricevuto io e di cui vi ho
parlato all'inizio non dovete neanche
vedere i dottori in questo caso è quello
che in gioco non è solo una vita ma
potenzialmente molti di più guardate io
nella vita ho studiato filosofia e
quindi ahimè oggi mi rimangono assai
poche certezze però alcune cose
beh io credo di saperlo una di queste
che se io mi guardo indietro e torna a
quel giorno dove ho deciso di andare
avanti e di diventare un donatore di
midollo osseo
anche se poi quella persona io non l'ho
mai conosciuta e non so nemmeno com'è
andata a finire
oggi io so che quel giorno fatto la
scelta giusta
e so anche che nella vita di tutti noi
alla fine arrivano questi momenti
cioè arrivano dei momenti nei quali ci
guardiamo allo specchio ci guardiamo
indietro e proviamo a determinare che
senso ha avuto la nostra esistenza
che tipo di persone siamo stati e che
tipo di mondo abbiamo veramente
contribuito a costruire tramite le
nostre scelte e tramite le nostre azioni
beh io credo che se voi oggi siete
disposti a cambiare la vostra
prospettiva riguardo all'altro ismea ciò
che voi potete fare per gli altri
se voi oggi siete disposti a entrare a
fare parte della conversazione che
stiamo cercando di lanciare noi anche
nel nostro paese riguarda i temi
dell'altruismo e della turismo efficace
e soprattutto se voi oggi decidete
magari qui e ora di rispondere di sì a
questa chiamata e di diventare degli
altri sti efficaci e dei donatori
seriali beh io credo che quando quel
momento della vostra vita
rivera magari domani magari tra
vent'anni magari l'ultimo giorno della
vostra vita
beh quando quel momento arriverà allora
potrete riguardare alle decisioni che
avete preso oggi sapendo anche voi di
avere fatto una cosa giusta
grazie
[Applauso]